[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland und
gleich vorab eine Warnung in der
heutigen Ausgabe geht es um den Tod von
zwei Kindern zwei Babys es geht um
plötzlichen Kindstod und eine Mutter die
wegen Mordes an ihren Kindern verurteilt
wird werden euch keine schrecklichen
Details erzählen aber falls euch diese
Dinge stark belasten dann raten wir euch
diese Episode besser zu überspringen und
lieber eine andere Ausgabe zu hören
außerdem geht es heute um Mathematik
damit haben wir jetzt möglicherweise
auch die restlichen Zuhörerinnen und
Zuhörer abgeschränken naja keine Sorge
das wird jetzt kein Mathe Podcast aber
wenn auf jeden Fall eine Menge einige
Zahlen denn vorkommen aber vielleicht
beginnen wir genau aus diesem Grund
erstmal mit einer schönen Geschichte
jetzt wir packen ein Happy End an den
Anfang denn unsere eigentliche Story die
hat keins im Jahr 19 196 gewinnt die
Lehrerin John R Ginter in der
staatlichen texanischen Lotterie 5,4
Millionen Dollar aber das ist erst der
Anfang
2002 gewinnt John mit einem holiday
Millionär Rubbellos zwei Millionen
Dollar und unglaublich 2008 knackt Sie
einen weiteren Lotto Jackpot und gewinnt
3 Millionen Dollar ja und 2010 da knackt
sie ihren eigenen Rekord und gewinnt in
einer Lotterie 10 Millionen Dollar und
nicht und das wars
Jackpots das reicht auch ganz ehrlich
das ist mehr Dusel als andere in ihrem
ganzen Leben haben absolut obwohl ich an
ihrer Stelle wohl weiter Lotto Lose
kaufen würde
definitiv Mirko also ich weiß nicht wie
es bei dir ist aber ich war in Mathe
ziemlich schlecht aber weißt du wie hoch
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist dass wir
beide auch vier Mal hintereinander
absahnen wenn wir jetzt anfangen würden
Lotto zu spielen also meine eigene
Erfahrung sagt mir da das ist wohl
utopisch
also für Jones Glückssträhne haben
Mathematiker eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von
1 zu 18 Quadrillionen ausgerechnet
Religionen Quadrillionen
sorry kenne ich nicht ich kenne doch
fantastisch Jagen von Dagobert Duck
also das ist fast das gleiche aber nur
fast eine quadrillion ist eine 1 mit 24
Nullen damit du das besser vorstellen
kannst mir kurz das ist ungefähr die
geschätzte Anzahl von Sandkörnern auf
der Erde oder von Sternen im gesamten
Universum
Toni vielen Dank jetzt kann ich mir
wenigstens was konkretes darunter
vorstellen
naja also wichtig ist nur dass eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit von 1 zu 18
Quadrillionen praktisch so gut wie
unmöglich bedeutet aber eben nur so gut
wie herzlichen Glückwunsch an John
argenta die das sehr eindrücklich
demonstriert hat und wir müssen John the
lucky is woman und Earth wie sie auch
manchmal genannt wird im Hinterkopf
behalten wenn wir die Geschichte einer
Frau erzählen die weiß Gott kein Glück
hatte ganz im Gegenteil Mirko erzähl uns
von Sally Clark Sally Clark wird im
August 1964
Sally lockier in der Gemeinde die weißes
in Südwestengland geboren sie ist ein
Einzelkind der Vater ist Polizist die
Mutter Friseurin Sally studiert in der
Southampton University Geografie und
arbeitet danach bei verschiedenen Banken
1990 heiratet sie Steve Clark einen
Anwalt ja und kündigt direkt ihren Job
aber nicht etwa um Hausfrau zu werden
und ihren Mann zu bekochen nee Sally
kündigt ihren Job um mir selbst Anwältin
zu werden sie studiert Jura an der City
University in London
1994 kaufen die beiden ein Haus auf dem
Land in der Nähe von Manchester und
Beginner gemeinsam in einer großen
Anwaltskanzlei zu arbeiten
am 22 September 1996 wird ihr erstes
Kind geboren Steven ein gesunder Junge
und das ganze Glück der Familie
aber das Glück wird keine drei Monate am
13 September wird Steven im Bett
bewusstlos der Notarzt wird gerufen der
Junge wird sofort ins Krankenhaus
gebracht doch es ist zu spät alle
Wiederbelebungsversuche bleiben
erfolglos Steven ist tot
die Diagnose plötzlicher Kindstod wir
wollen hier nicht darüber sprechen was
das für eine Mutter und ein Vater
bedeutet also was das für Sally und
ihren Mann Steve bedeutet hat es ist
unvorstellbar sowas durchmachen zu
müssen Sally erkrankt daraufhin an einer
Depression beginnt zu trinken doch die
beiden schaffen es sich aus dem tiefen
Tal herauszukämpfen sie wollen leben sie
wollen eine Familie und dann im November
1997 wird Harry geboren jetzt weiter
Sohn er kommt drei Wochen vor dem
errechneten Termin zur Welt aber es geht
ihm gut und nichts deutet auf das hin
was dann geschieht
[Musik]
im Januar 1998 acht Wochen nach seiner
Geburt stirbt Harry Clark
unerwartet und unerklärlich wie sein
Bruder Steven und plötzlich steht die
Frage im Raum ob es wirklich ein
tragischer plötzlicher Kindstod war oder
ob Sally Clark eine Mörderin ist
Sally war bei beiden Todesfällen mit den
Kindern allein zu Hause und die
Verletzungen an den Jungen die man
anfangs für Folgen der
Wiederbelebungsversuche hielt könnten
auch auf heftige Schütteln der Babys
zurückzuführen sein ja war vor allem wie
wahrscheinlich ist das denn das in einer
guten wohlhabenden englischen Familie
zwei gesunde Babys kurz nacheinander den
zum Glück sehr seltenen plötzlichen
Kindstod sterben und damit sind wir
wieder beim Anfang unserer Geschichte
denn vielleicht ahnte es schon warum wir
euch die Geschichte der vierfachen
lottogewinnerin erzählt haben Sally wird
es zweifachen Kindsmordes angeklagt am
11 oktober 1999 beginnt der Prozess und
am Morgen dieses Tages prankt auf der
Titelseite vieler Zeitungen eine Zahl 1
zu 72 Millionen um diese Zahl wird sich
im Folgenden fast alles drehen sie
stammt von einem Gutachter und
beschreibt laut ihm die
Wahrscheinlichkeit
für zwei infolge auftretende Fälle von
plötzlichem Kindstod okay also das
klingt sehr unwahrscheinlich nein also
das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich aber ich
sag nur eins zu 18 Quadrillionen für
vier Lottogewinne hintereinander und
trotzdem ist es ja passiert ganz genau
und unwahrscheinlich ist etwas
vollkommen anderes als unmöglich und
trotzdem ist diese Zahl vom Prozess
Auftakt an in den Augen der Presse der
Öffentlichkeit und der Jury so gut wie
ein Beweis für Sallys schuld was viele
nicht verstehen und ganz ehrlich ich
hätte das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
geschneit dass das folgendes
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit für zwei
aufeinanderfolgende Fälle von
plötzlichem Kindstod 1 zu 72 Millionen
beträgt das bedeutet nicht das umgekehrt
Sally mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von
72 Millionen zu 1 eine Mörderin ist es
bedeutet nur dass so etwas sehr selten
passiert okay und an dieser Stelle
nochmal ein Disclaimer wir sind dann
natürlich auch nicht schlauer als
wahrscheinlich viele von euch ich möchte
dabei niemandem zu nahe treten aber
Wahrscheinlichkeit zu verstehen gehört
sicher nicht zu den einfachsten Aufgaben
da sie unserem Empfinden zu widerläuft
und naja Matte nicht wirklich jedermann
Stärke ist also ich nehme mich da selber
nicht aus Zwinger zwinker
meine Stärke ist das auch nicht Mathe
Abi sechs Punkte und das auch nur durch
ganz viele Zeichnungen deswegen keine
Sorge Leute wir tauchen jetzt auch nicht
allzu tief in das Thema ab
okay aber zwei Sachen sind wichtig
erstens eins zu 72 Millionen heißt ein
Ereignis ist unwahrscheinlich aber
absolut im Bereich des Möglichen und
zweitens die Zahl ist falsch da hast du
Recht die Zahl ist tatsächlich falsch
der Experte der sie ins Spiel und den
Prozess bringt der kennt sich mit
Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung
offensichtlich genauso gut aus wie ich
tja und diesem Mann diesen Experten
müssen wir uns einmal genauer anschauen
Roy meadow
soy meadow bitte einer der bekanntesten
Kinderärzte seinerzeit in Großbritannien
1998 ein Jahr vor dem Prozess gegen
Sally Clark wurde er von der Queen zum
Ritter geschlagen und zwar für seine
Verdienste um den Kampf gegen
Kindesmissbrauch und Kindesmisshandlung
ein Mann der sich seinen Ritterschlag
wirklich verdient hat der mitgeholfen
hat diese Themen ins Bewusstsein der
Öffentlichkeit zurück Rücken etwas das
man ihm eigentlich gar nicht hoch genug
anrechnen kann und dennoch ja es gibt
auch eine dunkle Seite denn es kommt vor
dass Menschen die gegen etwas kämpfen es
plötzlich überall sehen die in ihrem
Eifer einfach über das Ziel
hinausschießen die eine Gefahr
übertreiben um ihre eigene Mission umso
wichtiger erscheinen zu lassen und die
keine Zweifel und keine Ungewissheit
mehr kennen
1989 veröffentlicht ein Buch mit dem
Titel ABC des Kindesmissbrauchs waren
formuliert er eine Regel die als madows
gesetzt bekannt wird
ich zitiere ein plötzlicher Kindstod ist
eine Tragödie zwei sind verdächtig und
drei sind Mord bis das Gegenteil
bewiesen ist
madows sagt im Prozess gegen Sally Clark
aus
bewaffnet mit der Zahl 1 zu 72 Millionen
mit Meadows gesetzt und der ganzen
Reputation eines zum Ritter geschlagenen
Kämpfers für Kinderrechte eine besseren
zeugen kann sich die Anklage eigentlich
gar nicht wünschen aber Mirko du hast
gesagt dass er sich verrechnet hat genau
er hat sich verrechnet die Zahl ist
falsch die Wahrscheinlichkeit für einen
plötzlichen Kindstod in einer Familie
wie der der Clarks betrug damals in
Großbritannien etwa 1 zu 8.500 für zwei
aufeinanderfolgende Fälle würde sie
deshalb eins zu 8.500 mal
8.500 betragen also ungefähr 1 zu 72
Millionen aber nach dem bisschen was ich
darüber weiß ist das doch korrekt oder
die Wahrscheinlichkeit eine 6 zu Würfeln
ist eins zu sechs die Wahrscheinlichkeit
zweimal hintereinander eine 6 zu Würfeln
ist 1 zu 6 mal 6 also 1 zu 36 ja das ist
richtig aber das gilt nur für
voneinander völlig unabhängige
Ereignisse wie etwa zwei Würfe mit dem
Würfel das Ergebnis des zweiten Wurfs
hat mit dem Ergebnis des ersten nichts
zu tun okay ein anderes Beispiel beim
Lotto spielen haben die Zahlen der einen
Woche absolut nichts mit denen in der
nächsten Woche zu tun aber das ist nicht
immer so
okay ich mache mal ein Beispiel sagen
wir mal 8 Millionen Deutsche spielen
jede Woche Lotto also ungefähr 10% der
Einwohner das ist jetzt natürlich kein
exakte Zahl sollte aber so ungefähr
hinkommen dann beträgt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass du dir diese
Woche ein Lotto los kaufst eins zu zehn
ah okay logisch aber wenn ich mir diese
Woche ein Lotto los kaufe dann sieht die
Wahrscheinlichkeit nächste Woche ganz
anders aus richtig ganz genau bei
jemandem der schon einmal oder öfter ein
Lotto losgekauft hat ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass er sich wieder
eins kauft viel höher als eins zu zehn
weil das natürlich miteinander zu tun
hat in diesem Fall wäre es vollkommen
absurd zu sagen dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass jemand zweimal
hintereinander Lotto spielt eins zu 100
sein okay also es ist schwer jetzt vom
Lotto wieder auf unser Thema
zurückzukommen aber so ist es auch beim
plötzlichen Kindstod ist dieser in einer
Familie schon einmal aufgetreten haben
später geborene Geschwister ein sehr
stark erhöhtes Risiko auch daran zu
sterben die Ursachen sind vielfältig und
nicht hundertprozentig geklärt aber es
spielen offenbar auch genetische
Faktoren hinein also ist Sally Clark
eine doppelte kinsmörderin oder eine
unschuldige Frau der zweimal das
Schlimmste widerfahren ist was eine
Mutter passieren kann ein Kind zu
verlieren Sally Clark ist unschuldig der
Tatort in dieser Episode ist nicht das
Haus der Clarks sondern der Gerichtssaal
die Tatwaffe diesen Taschenrechner denn
das was der vor Gericht passiert ist
eine Himmel schreiende Ungerechtigkeit
die Verteidigung widerlegt die
statistischen Taschenspieler Tricks von
madows und veranstaltet ihren eigenen
Zahlen Zauber unter anderem lässt sie
errechnen dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit
dass eine Frau aus einem Umfeld wie
Sally zur doppelmörderin an ihren
eigenen Kindern wird bei 1 zu 200
Millionen liegt
können wir bitte aufhören mit diesen
absurden Zahlen vor allem weil alle
gegenstatistiken und Experten die die
Verteidigung jetzt aufbringt Sally
sowieso nichts nützen gegen die
öffentliche Meinung gegen die
Schlagzeile der Presse über die Monster
Mutter und gegen die Autorität und
Präsenz des von der Queen geadelten
kinderretters da hat sie gar keine
Chance am 9 November 1999 wird Sally
Clark mit 10 von 12 Jury Stimmen
schuldig gesprochen und zu lebenslange
Haft verurteilt
[Musik]
boah durch welche Hölle ist diese Frau
bitte gegangen sie hat zwei Kinder
verloren und geht jetzt als deren
angebliche Mörderin ins Gefängnis ja die
Zeit im Gefängnis muss eine schreckliche
Qual gewesen sein nicht nur dass sie um
zwei Kinder trauert während die ganze
Welt da draußen sie für einen Monster
Held dazu kommt dass sie im Gefängnis so
ziemlich die meist gehasste Person
gewesen sein dürfte für die Mithäftlinge
ist sie nicht nur eine Kindsmörderin sie
ist auch Anwältin und Tochter eines
Polizisten zwei Dinge mit denen man sich
hinter Gittern nicht unbedingt Freunde
macht ja aber Sally kämpft und mit ihr
ihr Ehemann und einige Unterstützer es
kommt schließlich zum Berufungsverfahren
und das Gericht erkennt an dass madows
Statistiken falsch sind und lehnt die
Berufung aber dennoch ab
plötzlich sind die Zahlen anscheinend
nicht mehr wichtig man wendet sich
stattdessen Harrys Verletzungen die wie
gesagt auch von den
Wiederbelebungsversuchen stammen könnten
sowie Sallys Depressionen und vermutetem
Alkoholmissbrauch zu und begründet die
Rechtmäßigkeit des Urteils damit doch
ihr Ehemann Steve Clark gibt nicht auf
er durchforste die krankenhausakten
seines zweiten Sohnes Harry und wird
fündig
mikrobiologische Tests haben bei ihm
eine Besiedlung mit dem Bakterium
Staphylococcus aureus ergeben die bis in
seine Rückenmarks Flüssigkeit
vorgedrungen war der wahre Schuldige für
Harry ist tot ist damit gefunden aber
was wirklich übel ist die
Staatsanwaltschaft wusste schon vor dem
ersten Prozess von diesem Befund und
hielt ihn geheim er wurde weder dem
Gericht noch der Polizei bekannt gegeben
und schon gar nicht den Verteidigern von
Sally klagt
also da kann man nicht anders als ich
fragen wieso was überhaupt möglich ist
absolut und es ist ja nicht nur das ich
meine mellows der wichtigste
Belastungszeuge der war ja nicht blöd
der muss er gesehen haben dass seine
Statistik nicht stimmt sagen wir so er
müsste wie es zu all dem kommen konnte
darüber können wir hier nur spekulieren
ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand hier
wirklich eine unschuldige ins Gefängnis
bringen wollte ich glaube eher dass alle
insbesondere auch so matters glaubten
das Richtige zu tun und die Welt für
unsere Kinder ein bisschen sicherer zu
machen ja das glaube ich natürlich auch
und eine sehr menschliche Eigenschaft
ist es ja dass man wenn man von etwas
sehr überzeugt ist alle Informationen
die dagegen sprechen
ignoriert man vergisst sie oder
interpretiert sie um das ist etwas das
jedem von uns passiert und gegen das man
nur sehr schwer ankämpfen kann ja und
Experten sind davon halt auch betroffen
weil sie glauben alles über ein Thema zu
wissen ist für Sie jedes Gegenargument
automatisch falsch oder irrelevant ja
und jemand der wie maddos seine ganze
Reputation in die Waagschale geworfen
hat der dürfte sich umso schwerer tun
einen Fehler einzusehen
im Januar 2003 nach fast vier Jahren
Haft wird Sally Clark in einem zweiten
Berufungsverfahren frei gesprochen und
entlassen
aber bevor wir die Geschichte bis zum
bitteren Ende weiter erzählen schauen
wir noch mal auf Sir Roy meadow der hat
nämlich im Laufe der Jahre in vielen
ähnlichen Fällen ausgesagt 2002 wird
Angela kennings aufgrund von Meadows
Expertise wegen Mordes an ihren beiden
Kindern vorurteilt und sitzt 18 Monate
in Haft bevor ein Berufungsgericht ihre
Unschuld feststellt und das Urteil kippt
Donner Anthony die ebenfalls zwei Kinder
verlor sitzt von 1998 bis 2003 aufgrund
von Meadows Aussage unschuldig im
Gefängnis ja und für Mädels gibt's auch
Konsequenzen
2005 wird er wegen schwerwiegenden
beruflichen Fehlverhaltens aus dem Ärzte
Register komplett rausgestrichen
allerdings liegt er Berufung dagegen ein
und hat anders als Sally schon mit der
ersten Berufung Erfolg also bitte aber
es ist auch wichtig hier noch einmal auf
Mädels Verdienste hinzuweisen also ich
meine prinzipiell ist ja gut dass er
sich für diese Themen gesetzt und sie
eben auch für die Öffentlichkeit
zugänglicher gemacht hat seine Aussagen
vor Gericht haben zum Beispiel auch mal
geholfen um wirkliche Täterinnen hinter
Gitter zu bringen wie bei Maxime
Robinson die zwischen 1989 und 93 ihre
drei Kinder ermordete für Sally
jedenfalls war der Freispruch keine
wirkliche Erlösung zu ihrer Freilassung
sagte sie heute ist kein Sieg wir sind
nicht siegreich hier gibt es keine
Gewinner wir haben alle verloren Sally
wird leider nie wieder Fuß fassen sie
leidet an Depressionen und wird
alkoholkrank
2007 schließlich stirbt sie an einer
akuten Alkoholvergiftung
die Geschichte von Sally Clark haben wir
unter anderem anhand von Beiträgen von
The Guardian und bat Telegraph erzählt
aber auf den Fall aufmerksam geworden
sind wir durch die Episode Justizirrtum
wie wahrscheinlich ist die Wahrheit des
Podcasts die Science vom Deutschlandfunk
dort erfährte noch einiges mehr über
Sally Clark royadows und diese
verfluchte Zahl 1 zu 72 Millionen das
ist definitiv ein Tipp und wenn ihr
versprecht zu uns zurückzukommen dann
dürft ihr euch natürlich gerne mal
andersrum hören
Spaß kleiner Scherz also ihr macht
sowieso was ihr wollt und das ist auch
völlig in Ordnung und gut so wir danken
euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns wenn
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
seid euer Mirko und eure Toni